well if your new year's resolutions
involved exercise you're not alone but
if pushing our limits put you in pain
our next story has some tips to get you
back on track
new year new you or maybe not most
people try to change too much too fast
and they get overwhelmed and just like
everybody when you get overwhelmed
either procrastinator you quit don't try
to change everything all at once keep
track of your progress and be realistic
it may take a few months to get to those
activity goals you're looking for
or a few months to get to the way you
want to feel all the time
and there's going to be some pain and
aches and soreness on the way to help
manage those aches and pains dr andrew
conan and his colleagues came up with a
natural dietary supplement so we
developed our product called dr griggs
relief which is non-addictive fast
acting powder that tastes great you can
mix it in water any liquid that you like
can work as fast as 15 minutes it may
take several times per day to manage
your success stay focused on the end
game you know that old saying nobody
plans to fail and fail the plan well
that's very true and you need to ask
yourself what are you wanting out of an
active lifestyle do you want to look
better do you want to be healthier do
you want to feel better is it all all
the above learn more at doctorriggs.com